correct me if I'm wrong I'm sorry was
all the President's Men and adaptation
from Bernstein's book okay yes the
dialogue and that and the and and the
the the running I just remember and so
many scenes that were running and and
can you talk about that script in any
way you know I'm not as familiar with it
story is I mean with the script as I'd
like to because I mean I'd like to have
recently read the book and full script
but one of the things that you do in a
story like that is that you you add the
running because there probably isn't a
lot of running in real life I mean these
journalists are probably too heavy to be
running and they don't look like Robert
Redford probably either yeah some other
might but they're not you know but but I
think that that's what the big challenge
like spotlight is an example like they
took a lot of a lot of reporting from
Boston Globe and turned it into a
dramatic movie that covered
you know collapsed many years into a few
years you have to take those liberties
and that's why you end up saying
inspired by a true story instead of
based on a true story etc I've been
through that many times but adding
action adding drama is what you have to
do right in the scene in spotlight where
Stanley Tucci you don't see him yet you
just hear him yelling and his assistant
and so I think something's thrown and
then the look on Mark Ruffalo's face and
that right there is enough to threaten
of set the stakes exactly and it's exact
it's it's good drama because it involves
the audience immediately because you
don't see what's happening so you see a
reaction to what's happening so you have
to figure out what's happening and one
of the common mistakes that you know
younger writers make is that they
patronize the audience by explaining too
much by thinking that every single thing
has to be you know there and when I
always say that when you're editing like
the top ten rules of editing are all the
same cut cut cut cut cut cut because
when you're in doubt about whether you
need something that alone is a reason
for cutting it just cut it you don't
need it the audience will make the jump
and will fill in the blanks and if you
don't let them fill in the blanks
it's called painting by the numbers then
you come across this patronizing to the
audience and they they get bored they
don't want to hear every detail you
don't have to say your honor in a court
scene every every single sentence you
don't have to say the character's name
every time you talk to the character I
mean these are people get get that out
of their system after ten years of
writing but at the beginning you don't
know where the lines are and the sense
of the audience I mean one of the things
I like to talk about is the psychology
of the audience like it's not the
psychology of the author that makes you
read a book you don't care about that
you know it's just like you're listening
to your friend talk about his latest
ballad in the hospital I mean how much
do you care about how he felt about
every day you know you pretend you care
as long as you can but he has any sense
at all he'll keep it keep it you know
cut it down right and truth is you don't
care about the psychology of the
characters either that's not what's
important what's important is your
psychology as always the audience of
psychology and that's why a Hitchcock
and Peter we're really know what they're
doing that that drive away in witness is
one of the most brilliant parts of the
film because of the length of the
driveway so it was a location choice
he's telling the location manager I need
a place that has a long long long
driveway that will give me a 60-second
tracking shot you know and in the birds
when the heroine takes this flashlight
without even testing whether it works or
not and starts heading up the the wooden
steps because she hears rustling in the
Attic you know that is the longest walk
up the steps you've ever seen a film
because it is so stupid that the
audience needs it leads three or four
steps to get it out of their system
saying oh come on why is that every
actress when why does she have to have
white underwear on anyway so always at
the end of a horror film and why doesn't
she test that you know so once you get
past that okay now she's on the middle
step and then you go through like oh my
god why is she you know this doesn't
make any sense oh I can't stand this I
don't want to watch this and then a few
more steps and by the time she gets to
the top step you're ready like okay I
paid to get scared this is it and and
that is using the psychology of the
audience that's the timing that the
audience needs to get into the exact
right mood you know it's just like the
speech and Julius Caesar where Marc
Anthony comes up after Brutus is
brilliant speech on the you know corpse
of of Caesar and Anthony comes up and
praises you know Brutus is speech and
calls him the Honorable virtus and by
the end of his speech the kree's turned
the entire crowd against Brutus even
though they were all cheering for Brutus
at the beginning of his speech he takes
the psychology of the audience and
twists it around in a way that you know
you can see it coming but you don't care
you just want to go there with him and
it's not about anthony's nobody cares
about Antony's psychology you know and
nobody cares about Brutus and psychology
there that's not important nobody cares
about Shakespeare's psychology because
nobody knows what is chicken psychology
is they said you know the greatness of
homer and Shakespeare that they
themselves were nowhere to be found in
their work their characters were
everywhere
and the characters speak directly to the
audience you know and that that's the
hardest thing about writing just
figuring that out
you